PENG YING: Hi.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Peng.
And with me today is
my colleague, Maru.
MARU AHUES: Hi.
PENG YING: Hey, Maru.
Today we're talking about
the underlying concepts
of the Wallet Objects API, and
how everything works together
to give you the experience that
you see within the Wallet app.
Specifically, we're
going to be talking about
how data is stored
and represented,
and then how we can route this
data into the UI that you see.
Then we're going to talk about
how to insert and manipulate
this data using the
Wallet Objects APIs.
So first, to start off, let's
go over some of the concepts.
Here, what you
see is an overview
of the relationship
between templates, classes,
and objects.
Basically, classes and objects
define the data for a user.
Objects inherit
and extend the data
that's provided
within the class.
And then templates define
how to take this data that's
been populated with the
class and object, and then
render it in the UI.
So users are then
associated with this object,
and that's how users see
it within the Wallet app.
So how do we define templates?
Well, the templates
to use are actually
defined within the class.
Here, what you see
is that there's
a renderSpecs field
within the class, which
is an array that
defines the views.
There's two different
views that we care about.
The first one is the list view.
Now the list view is where
you see all of the objects
that a user has stored.
In this list view,
we're defining
to use the template
loyaltyCard1_list.
The second view that
we're concerned about
is the expanded view.
And the expanded view is when
a user clicks into the Wallet
Objects to find the details
of that Wallet Objects.
Here, for the details page
with our expanded view,
we've selected the
loyaltyCard1_expanded template.
We have a few templates
that are available now.
And we're working on
releasing additional templates
in the future.
So to find the latest, be sure
to check our documentation.
In this specific template
that we're showing right now,
we're defining the mapping
between the JSON data
and where it will be displayed.
For example, class,
that program logo
will be displayed
in the top left.
And program name will be
displayed in the header.
In the field name definitions
that you see here,
the class prefix
indicates that it's
a field that's defined
within the class.
And optic prefix
indicates that it's
a field defined
within the objects.
And a star indicates
that it can be
from either the
class or the object
because, as we stated,
earlier, the object inherits
from the class.
So you can have both.
Now let's dive into
the stored data.
A Wallet Objects class,
as we said earlier,
contains the common data
for all users of a vertical.
For example, in
the Loyalty Class,
we could contain common
data such as the program
image, colors,
the program names.
And the labels are common among
all users of that vertical
or of that Loyalty Class.
For an Offer, we can
store common information
such as maybe the merchant, the
fine print, the details, maybe
an image as well.
So the data is defined as a
JSON object, as we'll see now.
Here, we have an example
class from Belly.
Within this class, we're
defining all the content
that's common to all users.
Here we have some common
fields, such as the issuer name,
the unique ID, the program
name, the homepage.
Maybe you could even add things
such as a customer service
number.
We're also defining the
templates I want to use.
Here you see the renderSpecs
field defined as an array.
Just like we've
shown earlier, we're
using the
loyaltyCard1_list template
and the loyaltyCard1_expanded
template.
On the right, we see what
the list view templates would
look like, and what
the list view looks
like when you have a few objects
saved within a loyalty account
or within a Wallet
Objects account.
Wallet Objects contain
information specific
to each individual user.
For Loyalty, it could be
information such as the member
ID, the member name,
their barcodes,
or some personal messages.
For Offers, what you can do
is if you have a personalized
offer, it could be
unique information
such as the barcode itself.
Objects information is also
represented as a JSON objects.
In this example, we're
defining the user-specific data
for a Belly card that
we showed in the class.
And in this case, we
have user-specific data
such as the account ID, the
username, the barcodes, points,
and some other fields.
On the right is an example
of the expanded view.
And in this view what we've done
is we've taken the class data
and we've taken the object data.
We've merged those two together.
And now we're using a template
to render it and show it
within the Wallet app.
So now that we've kind of
discussed how data is formatted
and how it's rendered,
Maru will tell you
how to insert and
manipulate this data.
MARU AHUES: Thank you, Peng.
So now let's look
at ways that we
can insert classes and objects
into our Google Wallet app.
The first thing we can look
at is our RESTful APIs.
So we provide RESTful APIs to
insert, update, add messages,
and get your
objects and classes.
If you look at our
slide here, you'll
see that we have a URI to post
and insert a new Loyalty Class.
It looks very similar
for our Offer Class.
So the only thing
that's changing here
is the type of object
that we'll be inserting.
The same when we
try to do an update.
Then we just need
to put to this URI,
and then send the
resource ID, which
is the unique identifier
for the class in this case.
On the next slide,
we have the URIs
to get and update an object.
So from here you can see we're
getting the object, the Loyalty
Object, with a specific
ID which is also
unique in the system for that
merchant, for your merchant.
And also the URI to
update an object.
The same works for
offers, and for loyalties,
and for all our verticals.
What happens when we want
to insert a new object?
Objects can't be inserted
using the RESTful API,
so you have two
options to do that.
The first one will be using
the Save to Wallet button.
And for this, the consumer
will click on your Save
to Wallet button on
the web, and then that
will insert the object into
their Google Wallet app.
Or using the
Webservice API, which
only works right
now for loyalty.
And the way that we
use it is that when
you go into the Google
Wallet app and the member
clicks on I'm a member or I
want to join your program,
then that will call
your Webservice API.
PENG YING: Yeah.
And right now, the reason that
we don't offer saving objects
through the REST API is
because that these objects
need to be associated with
a Google user account.
And if you were just to
insert using REST with OAuth,
there's no way to
do that association.
So right now, it
needs, just like Maru
said, the Save to Wallet
or the Webservice API.
MARU AHUES: Great.
So now that we looked at
the list of the RESTful APIs
that we have, let's try to do
a demo and see how this works.
So the first thing we
need to do, of course,
is that we need to
obtain an OAuth2 token.
To do this, we provide a util
that's called TokenUtil.jar.
And of course you can obtain
this using your own code,
but this is the
easiest way I think.
So go into
github.com/googlewallet/walletobjects-utils,
as you can see on the
slide, and download the JAR.
And once you do that, let's
run it using your service
account email address
and your private key.
Once you run this, this
will create a token.
Old access tokens will
expire in one hour,
so as long as you're
within the hour,
then you should be able to
use that on every request test
that we do.
Let's first get a token.
OK.
So here I have the TokenUtil.
And I'm going to call it with
my service account email address
and my private key.
Once I do that, then
this is my token
that I'm going to be
using during this session.
Once we have the token,
let's try to insert a class.
So to insert a class,
this is the same URI
that I showed you before.
It allows us to post to
this URI with a class type.
We're going to use
Loyalty as an example,
but you could use
offers as well.
Then we also need to
send the bearer token
that we got using the TokenUtil.
And we need to send
the JSON for the object
that we want to create.
In this case, we can
either send it directly
when we do the call, or we
can send the path to a file
where we saved the JSON.
So let's do that.
The first thing I have
here-- and I already
have an example of a JSON
that we're going to use.
And this is very
similar to the example
that Peng was
showing before, where
we have the ID of our class.
So this is my
issuer ID, and this
is the unique ID for my class.
The issuer name, and I'm
also defining the templates
that I'm going to use
for list and expanded.
And I have some messages,
the links, some locations,
and the program name
and program logo.
All of these fields
are defined, of course,
on our documentation in
detail, which ones are required
and which ones are optional.
So a lot of these
fields are optional,
but we're showing
them here so you
can get an idea
of how this works.
So once we have that,
I save this on a file
called loyaltyclass.
And to create a new class--
I have here my cheat sheet
just so we can do this.
And I'm going to
create a new class.
So to do that, I'm going to
post to my Loyalty Class URI.
And I'm going to send the token.
But since I just created a
token, let me copy it again.
I'm going to replace
this on all of them.
Great.
So the first thing we'll do
is then create the class.
So what are we doing here?
We're posting to the URI,
we're sending the token,
and then we're sending
the JSON from this file.
Now once I run
that, this is going
to verify that the
token is correct,
that I have rights to do this.
And then it will
create the class,
and then it will return back
the class that it created.
So as you can see here,
this is our new class.
And if we go into our
Merchant dashboard,
we'll be able to see
the class created there.
Now if I wanted to do a Get to
see that my class was created,
all I need to do is--
let me do this up
here so it's easier to see it.
So we can see this is the URI
to get a class, a Loyalty Class.
And then this is my merchant ID.
And again, my unique ID
for my class in my token.
Once I do that, then I get the
class that we just created.
Cool, right?
Easy.
Then the next thing we're going
to do now is handling objects.
So we assume that
you already created
an object either using the Save
to Wallet or the Webservice
API.
And you have your
objects created here.
We can either get
an object or update
it, which is what you should
be doing when you want
to, let's say, update your
loyalty points on a Loyalty
Object.
To do that, we're going to
go back into our terminal.
And we're going to
get one of the objects
that we created before.
And this object was
created through the app.
So to do that, what I need to
do, then, is hit the same URI.
But now instead of Loyalty
Class, I call Loyalty Object.
The same issuer
ID, and then this
is the ID for my offer, which
is LoyaltyObjectPython1.
And then my token
Once I do that, this
is my Loyalty Object.
And you can see here,
these are all the fields
associated with the object.
And some of it, also as you can
see here, ClassReference, these
are the fields that
are coming, or they're
referenced by the class that's
associated with this object.
Like Peng says, the object
inherits some of the fields
from the class.
So once you do that
and you can see
that, let's see where
we have the points.
OK.
So we have points here, 500.
Let's update that and put 5,000.
So what we'll get here
is I'll copy this here
from my Get to update it.
And I'll save it in
this loyaltyobject file.
And I'll just make changes
to what I want to update.
In this case, my points.
So as you can see here,
I'm changing this to 5,000.
And I have to change two
more things to do an update.
One is we need to update
the version number.
So the version for
this object is 1.
We're going to update it to 2.
We have to increment the version
every time we do an update.
And also, we need to
change the review status.
Let me see where that is.
OK.
So this object is approved.
Let me see here.
Or no, the class
doesn't need that.
I think this is for the class.
OK I think that's
only for the class.
Let's just do it like this.
And to do the update,
all we need to do then
is instead of
doing a post, which
is what we do when
we create, we're
going to do a Put to update.
So to update, we're
updating the same object.
This is the ID, token, again.
And then we're
sending the content
that we have in
the loyaltyobject
file that we just created.
Right?
So we got back our object.
And now we should have
5,000 points in here.
Awesome.
So now you've learned
how to use our RESTful
APIs in test using cURL.
Of course, we provide libraries
to do this and sample code,
and you can find all of
this in our documentation.
PENG YING: We'll also have
additional tutorials about how
to use the Save to Wallet
and these Webservice APIs.
You can also find our
quick starts and tutorials
within our
documentation as well.
MARU AHUES: And
also, of course, you
know the URL to
our documentation.
And for other videos
and GDLs, just go
to
developers.google.com/live/wallet.
And you can find us also
on Google+ or Twitter.
Thank you for watching.
And we hope you
found this helpful.
Keep an eye out for additional
videos on our Google Developer
channel.
PENG YING: See you next time.
MARU AHUES: See you next time.